>> I think there's definitely a great chance
that China will pull us
out of the economic crisis that we're in.
A lot of the talk last year was about whether
China would be decoupled
from the rest of the world.
I think that's happened to a certain extent,
but I think we'll see that
investment in the Chinese domestic economy
has become so great that
it's pulling in a lot of imports from the
Asia -- the Asian-Pacific
region.
And I think this has stimulated the economy
in this particular region
and it's also dragging in imports from around
the world.
So I think the first steps will be an Asian-Pacific
recovery and the
then the recovery will spread to the rest
of the world.